what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as you guys know mondays are our time
to focus on what if stories like stories
that take place in the Marvel Universe
that we're not really in the Marvel
Universe but take place in the Marvel
multiverse that are part of alternate
realities now this story well there's no
other way to put it this story's just
crazy as hell I mean it's this is the
story about Aunt May becoming a Herald
of Galactus now I didn't know this was
the case I don't know about you guys but
sometimes I'll do searches like the most
ridiculous thing I can find like I was
looking up like all the heralds of
Galactus because I was like like what
people have been heralds of Galactus and
what's the most ridiculous thing on your
fun I found Thor being a Herald of
Galactus I found a story where Deadpool
was a Herald of Galactus and then I
found a story where Aunt May became a
Herald of Galactus and I was like well I
got read this comic um hisses is gonna
be one of the craziest and things I've
ever seen and it is it is absent it's
absolutely not so here was the deal and
not JT Ford Marvel did this thing where
it was like assistant editors um that
were the ones taking over many it was in
April that he was part of the April
Fool's joke but it was the idea that
they were handing over the reins of
other publications to the assistant
editors and they were gonna be the ones
that decided what stories were gonna go
out and what stories weren't now of
course again it was just kind of a
practical joke but it was really just
this idea of putting out just ridiculous
stuff and one of the guys I think a guy
by the name of Mike Carlin ended up
writing this story about all maybe being
a herald of kawatche it's now though hey
this opens up the way this opens up we
essentially have Galactus dealing with
Frankie Rey now at the time Frankie Rey
was a legitimate Herald of the light and
she was really like I think the one that
took over after the Silver Surfer
defected and she was kind of like the
Human Torch I mean she had cosmic powers
but she would flew around with her hair
on fire and it was like a reflection on
1980s big hair you know hair style so on
and so forth but in this particular
story a Frankie Rey had been killed and
the reason why is because Galactus was
going to consume a planet and the people
who are on that planet were like well
maybe if we destroy our world it'll
basically postpone Galactus is hunger to
the point that he'll literally starve to
death it kind of happened it almost
happened
you know he was starving up until he
wasn't but Ricky Ray actually ended up
dying here so the result was like
Galactus was like well we gotta go find
a new hero but we gotta find somebody to
take over the duties of Frankie ray
transition to the circus the the
Ringling Brothers Barnum and Bailey
Circus this is back in the day when
Marvel would use like pop-culture
references and it would use real world
things this because of the fact that I'm
pretty sure that Hani was just good
advertisement but the basis here is that
we have Peter Parker and we have on May
along with Mary Jane Watson showing up
to the circus now the funny thing about
this and something to keep in mind is
that no one knows that Peter Parker is
spider-man again this you know Mary Jane
Watson doesn't know Aunt May doesn't
know it's still a very intrinsic part of
his character and his identity is hidden
away from the rest of the world but the
other half of this is that Peter Parker
and Mary Jane Watson this is when they
were going through their spurt of being
broken up and so the result was that he
gave you know two extra tickets to on
may under the expectation that she was
going to end up bringing one of her
friends but instead she brought Mary
Jane because the idea was to get Peter
Parker and Mary Jane back together again
now from here we're also joined by
Franklin Richards and the Fantastic Four
and so it's it's kind of a funny
situation here because this isn't
actually unreasonable this is not
outside of the realm of expectation
because all these heroes are operating
out of New York City and so when
Ringling Brothers comes to town
everybody goes I'm Olivia I've ever been
the Ringling Brothers but everybody goes
to the Ringling Brothers Circus and I've
mended that thing in years I don't even
know if it's still around but you know
when it comes to New York everybody goes
oh it's realistic to believe that the
Fantastic Four and spider-man would be
there is insanely unrealistic to believe
they'd be sitting right next to each
other but this is the realm of comic
books and we are dealing with a giant
purple man that serves the spaceways and
absorbs the energy of planets so we
really kind of have to walk away from
actuality and facts and just kind of go
with the suspension of disbelief here
but the idea is that Reed Richards you
know as he's trying to crane around and
see what's going on he sees a headline
about some event of San Diego now this
is all just you know simple convenience
this is really just Mike Carla said hey
we'll just give the Fantastic Four a
reason to leave and let's give a
spider-man a reason to go with them and
so because of this the Fantastic Four
take off and spider-man Peter Parker's
like well you know I mean maybe I can
help them out and he ends up going with
them as well and so what this does is
this gives on May the chance to turn to
the Fantastic Four and say hey you know
I couldn't help it over here your
problem I'll keep an eye on Franklin
Richards while I'm here or at least
until you guys get back and then you
take him back home wherever it is you
guys are gonna do now this is where the
story goes from this is kind of
interesting - what in the hell is going
on because there's always reading
through this oh it was like the more I
read it the more I was like this is
insane but the more I read it the more I
was also like I really have to make a
video about this so we have Galactus
arriving on earth and his immediate
first step is to contact Reed Richards
and this makes sense you know because
for those of the guys who were familiar
with the history of Galactus or have
read you know the stories of his
character or saw my videos on his
publication of history or Jonathan
Hitman's Fantastic Four
ever since Reed Richards basically
fought Galactus off by threatening to
destroy him with the ultimate nullifier
there's always been this sort of respect
between the two
you know Galactus and he would never
consume earth but he has a lot of
respect for Reed Richards because of his
intelligence because of his efforts as a
superhero because of the fact that he's
explored so much of the universe and
he's charted so much said the South air
and been as much of a chronicler as he
has been a guide that acts in accordance
with the stereotypical beliefs of a
superhero and so because of this
Galactus shows up and says Reed you know
I need your help because we would expect
the lackeys to turn to Reed Richards as
one of the smartest people in the
universe and say hey I need you to help
me satiate my hunger for the time being
the issue with this is that when
Galactus arrives because Reed in the pit
hazard for in San Diego they're not
there but Galactus also senses the
energy of Franklin Richards now the
indication here from Mike Carlin is a
technically speaking this is the first
time that Galactus is encountering
Franklin Richards in the history of
Marvel Comics granted this is a what-if
story but as far as I'm aware this is
the first time they ever actually meet
and so Galactus you know follows its
energy signature and ends up at the
circus and tears the top off of these
drips the top off now of course you got
people running for their lives people
are fleeing and they're panicking and so
on Neil but Galactus immediately senses
Franklin Richards because his idea is to
make Franklin as Herald just because of
the raw reality warping power that he
possesses but when this happens when he
makes his presence known on made it
starts giving him the business made
history and her day you know she shows
up she's like dude you can't show up
here and start tearing people's stuff up
you can't rip the tops off circus
buildings and you can't he'll come in
here and destroy my day which is
legitimate I mean without may won't be
tied the poor soil the ruins her day
because they get read though riot
that's exactly what Galactus is getting
now you know in all seriousness things
begin to transition towards on May
becoming a Herald of Galactus when
Galactus immediately attacks Franklin
with the intention of making him his
arrow but what not May does is she
basically jumps in the way to protect
Franklin and she's blasted with the full
might of Galactus is power in making her
a Herald and she emerges but he emerges
as the golden oldie that is her name
she's calling yourself the golden oldie
now what happens as Galactus held on a
look you know I didn't expect you to be
the one that would become a hero but
whatever sometimes we just gotta deal
with the hands that were dealt and he
says you know my hunger is killing me
right now
I need you to go and find a source of
sustenance now Franklin Richards steps
up in true child fashion and says hey
I've got Twinkies have some angle
actress eats them and Galactus is
satisfied with them now rob core members
of the rock or let's take a second right
now
to acknowledge the fact that Galactus is
eating Twinkies Twinkies and their
satiating is hunger they're keeping his
hunger a day God does is eating Twinkies
right now but what he does is he tells
Aunt May he says look these Twinkies are
amazing which Twinkies are amazing and
he says go find me some more so of
course Aunt May begins to write it's a
golden oldie begins to scour the planet
from grabbing all the Twinkies she can
find him and she just runs up on folks
and just snatches the Twinkies out of
their hand and this is the dumbest thing
I've ever seen and is a taking in the
Galactica's but the problem with this is
that galactus as hunger is almost
infinite I mean he's always needing to
consume energies and so the most
illogical situation happens when he says
hey look you know this is not enough I
need all the Twinkies you can give me
and so she literally you know gives him
all the Twinkies on the face of the
earth and because of this because he's
still hungry he basically sends her into
the cosmos for the purpose of finding
more Twinkies for him or at least
finding you know the traditional planets
that he can consume now during her
journey she ultimately comes across a
giant Twinkie planet now the idea here
for her this is insane the idea you guys
better appreciate this video like I want
to be seeing some likes all right I
wanted to be seeing some comments you
know and that's again I want to see some
appreciation because this isn't
same now when she goes and you know when
she first encounters a planet she was
immediately attacked by what amounts to
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man or Ike
it's not really saying much marshal man
the Pillsbury Doughboy there we go
you know she's attacked or at least you
know met with the arrival of the
Pillsbury Doughboy now what we learn is
that the Pillsbury Doughboy was believed
by his people to simply be creating
Donuts and so they banished him from
their planet what he says is he's not
just creating Donuts he's creating
planets that just also happened to be
Twinkies and so when Galactus arrives
you know he says look I'm gonna consume
this planet I mean that's just the way
it is you know I'm going to eat
everything here now the Pillsbury
Doughboy begs and pleases look you can't
do this man you can't consume the planet
but Galactus is like yeah man this is
gonna happen
um now here's a cool thing about this
story though at all serious and here's
the cool thing about this this is just
fun I mean the story's not meant to be
taken too seriously you know obviously
it's not meant to be something that
leads to some grandiose thing it's
literally just having a good time but we
don't see things like this very often
because Marvel very rarely delves into
something as ridiculous as this I mean a
truth
Deadpool is about as goofy and silly as
Marvel gets in this day and age we're
back in the 1980s it was literally just
write whatever you want to and he had
Jim shooter who was editor-in-chief and
as long as they made their deadlines and
as long as they followed editorial
mandates for what it is that he had
going on at that particular point in
time you know they were just kind of
free to do whatever they wanted to grant
if Jim shooter ran here and Marvel with
an iron fist and a lot of people hated
him because of his editorial mandates
but when it was time to play it was time
to play and a lot of the writers were
very very good at what they did and so
the Oh Galactus initially makes his way
in with the intention of consuming this
planet but then we also have the
Pillsbury doughboys step up and say hey
look you know I'll sacrifice myself I'm
literally a guy with an infinite source
of doughy deliciousness and you are
welcome to consume me and it will
satiate your hunger for evermore and so
the Galactus does that Galactus quite
literally just consumes that Pillsbury
Doughboy and so at this point you know
on May there's really no need for her
anymore so she was essentially just kind
of freed from her captivity and she's
allowed to return to Earth and when she
does we of course have the return of the
Fantastic Four we have the return of
Spock
and then we suddenly realized this was
all a dream in the mind of Peter Parker
he just wakes up in the middle of the
night and realizes that it was all a
dream it was all just supposed to be you
know something some kind of a joke but I
mean the story's fun for what it is it's
ridiculous
but it's fun for what it is he always
kind of good old-fashioned goofing
around Marvel style you know that kind
of thing but if you guys are new here to
comics explain and you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you hit the subscribe
button if you guys like this and you
know nothing like and leave a comment
down below because I don't usually do
videos like this very often but it is
fun to do them every once in a while
just because I think doing something
like this to consistently would drive
even me nuts you know but it's very
important with comic books to recognize
that comics are just supposed to be a
source of entertainment I mean you know
coming books are just supposed to be a
source of fun at the end we really
should just be enjoying them and so you
know while that while there will be
people who will hate this there also be
people who will love it and that's the
beauty of comics is that you know people
see things from different perspectives
and everybody enjoys different things
but webbing said we're gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end and yeah
I will catch you all in it peace
[Music]